definitely ready standing by with the
man of the name
thank you so much Spiro what a game walk
us through that third quarter when
Minnesota went on the Run how were you
all able to maintain your composure and
get back in the game well we've been in
that position before
um you know the Huddle's really positive
you know we didn't get down to each
other we knew we had to do and I think
we did a good job of just selling
ourselves down and executing down the
stretch offense of the end defensively
now I know your coach Michael Malone you
say the huddles were really positive is
that players or including coach oh
concluding coach I thought coach had a
great game plan for us um we slacked off
a little bit in the third but you know
we stuck with what we do and um you know
it worked so you know I thought coaches
did a great job and I thought the team
did a great job like I said executing
saw the Embrace that you shared with him
just moments ago you've been through a
lot getting back to this point what was
that moment that you all shared
uh there's only one Jamal so uh he just
reminded me of that um
you said it took a lot to get
to get a doubt a lot of unknowns a lot
of fears but it was nice to see it
through and um
see it through you and I have talked to
this entire season about the process
that you've gone through the Journey do
you feel like this is it you're back now
I mean like I said it's been
I'm just trending I knew I knew it was
going to be up and down season for me I
knew I was going to have bad moments
store moments uh rough moments so I knew
I was going to have a uh my adrenaline
going in the first couple playoff games
the energy here is undeniable so I kind
of planned for it but it was nice to
settle down like I said and and just
play my game before I let you go how's
that knee feeling it's feeling good
thanks for stopping nice job appreciate
it guys all right Stephanie great stuff
what a moment for Jamal Murray 18 months
that long rehab he is back yeah all the
hard work
physically mentally emotionally that
he's been through
all paid off here to be back to be back
at this level having this kind of moment
in effort for his team